Start the day by sipping a cup of Maple Bacon
Coffee and capturing the world from your dog’s
point of view with Fetch - the GoPro dog harness.
But first please put on your pants…shirt.
Because it’s episode 45 of LÜT.
Let your lunch travel slimly and safely with
the Foodskin flexible lunchbox - that compactly
keeps food fresh and prevents meat from getting
mangled.
Purchase something to pig out on using funds
from a scented Belgian waffle coin purse.
Or curb the cash and just carry cards with
the Decadent Minimalist One - a wallet made
out of a single piece of aluminum that securely
carries up to eight identification or credit
cards.
Which you’ll probably need to pay for this
Ferrari carbon fibre chess set.
Finger Hands.
Feed your feet dessert with Shoe Bakery.
Fancy confectionary footwear from ice cream
flats to pink cake wedges.
If those don’t float your boat just float
tiny objects with sound.
The Ultrasonic Levitation Machine is designed
to allow people to experiment with anti-gravity
fields created by sound.
So maybe we can someday have a hoverboard?
Visualize sound with Light Show Fountain Speakers
that are compatible with all USB-friendly
music devices and time your tunes with a light
and water show using 4 multi-colored LEDs.
Change the color of your cleanliness by installing
glass shower tiles that feature distinct designs
depending on the temperature.
They appear black at room temperature and
color variations range from Northern Lights
to Tye-Dye.
Try to chew on chemistry by making your own
chewing gum.
Adult supervision recommended.
Being an adult is required when enjoying the
beer briefcase.
But to stay hydrated in the wild there’s
the Katadyn Pocket water filter built for
a lifetime of use thanks to a silver-impregnanted
ceramic filter.
Use Reviveaphone to bring your phone back
from a watery death.
Pour the solution into the pouch, power down
your phone, put it in there for 7 minutes
and it removes destructive mineral residue
on the motherboard - resurrecting your water-damaged
mobile.
Then charge it with sun power with the port
solar charger that has an integrated suction
cup allowing it to stick to any window.
Stick to swear words if you want to win uhhhh
f asterisk asterisk k tionary.
The adults-only dirty word game described
as Cards Against Humanity meets Scattergories.
Technology meets tailoring with the MTailor
app - that lets you customize every aspect
of your shirt from fabric and collar to cuff
style and then uses your mobile device’s
camera to measure you 20% more accurately
than a professional tailor.
Giving you perfect fitting custom shirts from
the comfort of your jellyfish chair.
Which you can sit back on and relax while
you stare at your six million digits of pi
poster.
Finally, fly your giant 50 foot long solar
balloon in preparation for your World View
Balloon Voyage to the edge of space - which
for only $75,000 per passenger - will float
you 100,000 feet from the ground.
Y’know what?
A fall from that height and you just might
reach Terminal Velociraptor.
And as always - thanks for watching!